so the first trailer for renfeld came
out this morning and I could not be more
excited it looks pardon my language
[ __ ] awesome
um and I I love your look in it and uh
Robert told me that it was your idea to
wear all the Rings
um uh in the film and I'm just curious
could you talk a little bit about coming
up with the look of of Dracula well I
had a lot of help there were there were
a ton of super talented people on that
movie that
you know helped design the the look
um
you know we wanted it to be more
homage and more Christopher Lee I
favored Christopher Lee as Dracula and I
liked his kind of 60s hairdo and
um
but the Wardrobe the costume and no I
didn't come up with the idea for the
Rings uh that all came out of a wardrobe
they came in with all that
maybe maybe they sent something in me
that I would I would like that but I
that was really on that was their their
contribution what is it like because
you've done so many roles through your
career what is it like getting the phone
call hey we're making a movie and we
want you to play Dracula right well
first of all I don't know how you say no
to Dracula but but two things come to
mind one it's a it's a character he's a
character that's been done well many
times and didn't been done poorly many
times so
you want to be on the side of doing
something well and also you want to be
on the side of doing something fresh and
something that pops you know and to me
because the movie's really not about me
I don't I don't Dracula rather I don't
have a lot of screen time it's really
Nick Holtz movie and it's about Renfield
I didn't have the time like the narrow
the two-hour narrative to really dig
deep into Dracula's pathos per se it's
not that but I did have enough screen
time to be able to try to develop a pop
art style to the character that
hopefully will be a nice contribution to
the other performers that have done it
that have had their take on on this
legendary character in in both
literature and Cinema